now he has to play Rook G3 everything
else is basically made into
and black
will finally be able to get up
and take a drink of water you know
splash some water on his face and
perhaps he finds Bishop B6 finally
and then he is winning oh wow it looks
like
um someone has lost on time
no Prague has lost on time uh it was a
difficult position lost position anyway
yeah
this does not look particularly savable
or salvageable or whichever way you want
to go about things but it's it's
unfortunate to to actually lose on time
here but yeah I don't think
I don't think he's drawing chances here
are particularly High
yeah there's points of Dreams long term
yeah I'm slightly wondering why we're
allowed King A5 to be honest
unless there is some kind of a mate to
the King on A5 straight away I wouldn't
have been allowing this